the Congo Basin rainforests are the home
of the bonobos these great apes are
extremely shy anyone trying to film them
needs patience and luck
Lenovo spent most of their time in the
treetops foraging for leaves and fruit
the World Wide Fund for Nature
conservation efforts in the west of the
country have been underway for a few
years primatologists Aliyeva tiger and
her colleagues got up early to go and
look for the bonobos nest bonobos build
a nest every night out of branches that
they weave together to make a sort of
platform it's a way of ensuring that
they're protected and of course it
provides them with a place that's dry
this nest here is about six meters above
ground but you can find others that are
up to 25 meters above ground very high
but even this doesn't guarantee the
bonobos protection against their arch
enemy man coming across bonobos who are
still alive is always a relief for Livia
vitoca and her team bonobo is an
endangered species only found in the
Democratic Republic of Congo the bonobo
population here in the rainforest
numbers between 20,000 and 50,000 they
live in just a few pockets of the forest
the main threat that they face is loss
of habitat due to farming and forestry
hring a further problem is bushmeat
hunting but no bows are still eaten I
put in credit for the effort
gitche Wamba is the WWF conservation
projects local coordinator if the
rainforests aren't protected their
riches are highly vulnerable to
exploitation the environmentalist wants
to ensure that there's enough natural
habitat for the bonobos in the long term
we've been working here on bonobo
conservation nema label region for ten
years including getting them used to a
human presence as well as this long-term
project we're working closely with the
timber companies in the area a local
cattle farm and local communities these
combined efforts are designed to provide
maximum protection of biodiversity
including the bonobos the human
population in the region is on the rise
and with it hunting and farming locals
nevertheless support the conservation
efforts which unfortunately is the
exception rather than the rule in the
country how much the environment gets
protected is up to the village chiefs to
decide the bonobos are not at risk here
it's our tradition to protect them we
don't hunt them we don't kill them and
if we encounter them in the forest we
treat them with respect we see them as
human but respect alone won't ensure
their survival recent years have seen
the WWF boost its conservation program
stepping up efforts to protect the Congo
Basin rainforest
the region is home to great stretches of
savanna and grassland vast areas have
been slashed and burned to make way for
cattle farming
those are all good cellphone for a
second there it's not that the biggest
problem here is that trees grow up in
the grazing areas so we constantly have
to burn them down and that obviously
takes its toll on the forests that is a
serious problem environmental awareness
is an important first step
conservationists and farmers are working
together to tackle the forest fire
problem we train locals in forest
management this also creates jobs
because now there's a call for people
trained in fire management on the one
hand we're helping look after the
rainforest and boosting biodiversity and
on the other
we're boosting locals incomes the
project area now encompasses about a
million hectares of land including a few
timer companies tropical wood is highly
lucrative
the trade in timber needs to be factored
into the conservation efforts the
well-being of the rainforest is key to
climate protection one local company has
already announced plans to work more
sustainably
WUF works with timber companies because
biodiversity needs to be protected in
areas where logging takes place we need
to protect the local flora and fauna the
WWF supports these company's efforts to
protect biodiversity in the areas where
they're active for the time being those
efforts are relatively modest logging is
forbidden on the fringes of the
rainforest and the banks of streams at
least these areas are safe for the local
wildlife but the bonobos need a bigger
habitat than that their survival
hinges on a fully intact rainforest
you